hey BuzzFeed it's Nikki I'm gonna be
answering 30 questions in three minutes
I'm very nervous here we go pink I've
been listening to if I knew by Bruno
Mars a lot money trees by Kendrick Lamar
be yourself don't try to be anyone else
because everybody else is taking it's
super cliche and super tumblr 2014 but
here we go
[Music]
my phone like a cell tower and about I
don't know oh oh Sean Miyashiro Kacey
Musgraves loyal ambitious kind rude
people boyhood oh the the glitter one oh
I have six currently the sparkle emoji
that's my next one okay it's a tie
between chocolate chip cookie dough or
anything like birthday cake I texted my
dad and I said hahaha you're weird
Thank You YouTube sorry Netflix
or alive alive I'd love to meet Mason
Ramsey they're really cool I don't know
if you'll ever watch this but dead
probably like Confucius Oh understand
any language for sure
I love languages to understand every
language nothing I had two sips of my
very cold chai tea which was supposed to
be hot which upset me but it's okay ooh
probably illallah lost you tether can
message chill be nice don't get up yeah
there you go
I did it 30 questions in three minutes
now you know all the more about me
sidenote
ato rising my amazing collective we just
released head in the clouds to our
collective album so go listen to that
thanks must be until next time
[Music]